はぁぁ
2011年
東区庁で大震災がありましたよね
皆さんの時
もしもに備えて
備蓄されましたか
今年も
西日本語をはじめ
大阪北部地震
さらには北海道でも震度ならの大震災が起こりました
これだけ毎年各地で震災が起こっていても
ほら大丈夫
と心のどこかで思っていませんか
そう思ってて国は元でも2016年大きな震災がありました
皆さんも経験あると思うんですけれども
今2年半過ぎましたが皆さんの家やどうでしょうか
水や食料を備蓄されてますでしょうか
喉元過ぎればという方も多いのではないでしょうか
交通事故や障害も同じだと思います
ある日突然自分の身に襲いかかってくるのです
そして
これらを防ぐ手立ては残念ながらありません
私にもある日突然大きな不幸が襲いました
右足をなくしたんです
4年前の出来事です
足をなくした直後は大変落ち込みました
そしてこれからの生活は
そして仕事は
どうなるんだろう
大きな不安を感じていました
その後幸いにも義足を使うことができて
失った右足の機能大方取り戻すことができました
しかし車の運転だけは利息ではどうしても無理でした
そんなときこんな私でも車の運転ができると言う
テクノロジーがあることを知ったんです
それから私の第2の人生が始まりました
岩間ぜ普通にやってたことがあ
ある日突然できなくなる
とてもつらいことです
皆さんも経験があると思います
秀才にあった時や病気になったときに
何気ない日常が
ありがたいなぁ
とっ
わかる体験があると思います
失って初めてそのありがたさに気づくのです
私にとっても車の運転はそんな日常の一つでした
ですから足をなくしたと思う
またどうにかして車の運転をしたい
そういうふうに強く望みました
右足を切断して半年か
移動したもんかなーとどうしたら運転できるのかなと悩み続けていました
そんな次にワンペダルを知ったんです
しかもその会社は同じ熊本にありました
私は左足でも運転ができるかもしれない
そんな大きい期待を胸に
1ペタルの市場に臨みました
そして車の運転をして
ちゃった9分 a
悩みは解決しました
ワンペダルの操作を説明を受けて5分後には左足で
構造を
走らせたんです
車の運転おおおお
という日常を取り戻した瞬間でした
その日のことは鮮明に今でも覚えています
とても感動しましたし
心から感謝しました
そして今ではこのように
運転をしています
これ私が運転占領すです
特に足元に注目してご覧いただきたいと思います
ペダルを踏んだり
横につだしたり
横にずらしたりペダルを踏んだりしてますね
今ペダルを踏んだり横にずらしたりしてましたけど
意味わかりますかね
じゃ分あのー弾何やってんだと皆さん思われたと思うんですけれども実はペダルを踏ん
だのがブレーキです
で横にずらしてたのが開くさんがアクセル
なんですよね
今皆さん足を横にずらすあ
それでたいんじゃないのと思われたかも知れませんので今から実際に皆さんにも一緒に
そのずらす動作をちょっと一緒にやってもらいたいなと思います今座ってる座席をです
ね
運転席だと思ってくださいで私は左足なんですけれども皆さんは右足を軽くトントンと
ちょっと前に
だしていただいて
かかとをトントンで足先を宙に浮かせます
で足先を踏み込むとブレーキです
でまずはじめに足首崎を使って外側にずらしてください
横に
ちょっときついと思うんですよね次に膝と足先を同時に外側に開いてください
そうです
そうするとら9人
足をずらすことができると思うんですよね
ですからワンペダルは
膝を
使って操作すると
いうイメージです
で実際私の車とについている
全く同じタイプのもう系をこちらの準備しています
これが番兵なるのです
ちょっとごついですよね
これを私が乗ってた車に取り付けただけです
それで左足で運転できるようになりました
しかも
このワンペダルは小さな町工場でその車1台石才に合わせてハンドメイドで作られてい
ます
運転を再開してから約2年くらいが経った頃でしょうか
今日みたいな雨が降っている日でした
朝の通勤時間いつものように私は車を運転せました
そうしたら横から急に飛び出してくる曲がったんですね
そこで私はワンペダルから溝部の感動をプレゼントしてもらいました
飛び出して来たんですけれども
車は
直前にぶつかる直前に泊まることができたんです
自信を持って断言していますワンペダルだから
ぶつからなかったんです
なぜか
牛を今から説明しますが説明するよりも
百聞は一見にしかずですから
こちらをご覧ください
私はまあ左足で運転していますので左足をこのようにして
横にずらしてアクセルを操作していますこれがタイヤを
イチョウ
発生していますのでこの状態だとクルマが走ってる状態ですよね
で皆さんは特に9ブルーのところ今モニターに映ってないんですかね
心ブルームところにちょっと着目してほしいんですけども
も率あげませんかね
ちょっとこのところにですねちょっとちっちゃいですけど
注目しておいてください
今走っています危ない
わかりましたかねここが外れるんですよねもう一度します
アクセルをやってて
ふむ
ちょっと反応がないんで寂しいんですけれども普通だった
oo みたいなぁとが多いですけども
あの拍手は催促しません
はい
ちょっと今モニターも打つなかったし私もちょっと今とりまぎしてるんですけれども
ということでこの今拍手を頂いたのは
結局危ないと思ったら通常でしたらアクセルからブレーキに踏み換えて旧暦をします
けれども
ワンペダルの場合はアクセルをかけた状態でもそのままプレイ
行踏むことができるでアクセルは自動的に解除するということなんですよ
ですからまあより早く車を止めることができるのでへ
事故を防ぐということだったんですよね
すいませんさきほどこういった工場の中で一つすハンドメイドで作っています
で
昨年日本では50万件の交通事故が発生しました
そのうちの半分が交差点周りで起きた
出会い頭の事故
だったんですよ
猛スピードでバーンと端にぶつかる事故ばかりじゃなくて
皆さんも経験あると思うんですけれども
あと数センチあと数メーター
車が早くとまったら
ツイートしなかったのにな
接触しなかったのになあという事故がとても多いんですよね
ワンピ猿の場合は先ほどほどのように
踏めば止まりますから踏むと椅子でも止まるという安心感をもって
操作ができるのが非常に
ありがたい
そしてとても重要なところです
せさらに最近では
高齢者による二位間違いもニュース事故のニュースがよく流れてますよね
それを受けて
高齢者は早く免許返納すべきだという与論も大きくなりつつあります
しかし皆さんどうでしょう
実際この熊本に住んでまして70を過ぎて車の辺の免許のへんもできますか
買い物にも行けませんし
車って生活に欠かせない足じゃないですか
しかし全国で踏み間違いの事故っていうのは毎年5000件から6000件発生してい
ます
こんなに多く発生していますから明日は我が身
になっても全然不思議じゃないんですよね
しかしワンペダルの場合はピザが一つですから降り間違いは100%しません
コンビニに突っ込んだり登校中の児童の列を跳ねたりそういう悲しい事故っていうのは
ないんですよね
最近では
自動ブレーキや踏み間違い防止の装備も新車には標準装備されつつあります
しかしはんぺらの場合には新車に買い換えることなく今乗ってらっしゃる車に創立から
できるというポイントも大きい
こちらそう思う
またワンペダルのリグ者の中にはこういう方もいらっしゃいます
熊本県にお住まいの59歳の男性の方です
この形は
小児脳性麻痺という病気である2型つも
歩行器を使って歩かれています
これまでは普通の車に乗っていらっしゃったんですけれども
今年の7月に
事故を起こされました
カーブに差しかかった時に
ブレーキペダルに足が引っかかって合わせてブレーキとアクセルを同時に踏まれたそう
なんですよね
そして車が暴走して10メートルの高さから車ごと
かつや臭いぞそうです車は当然大破
しかし本人は幸いにも軽傷で積んだらしいです
そんな事故を踏まえて家族の方ももう運転をやめるようにと彼を説得したそうです
しかし彼はかたくなに運転を続けると主張したそうです
身体が不自由な彼にとってなんか人の役に立ちたいと
勇気を持って実は日々生きていらっしゃったんですね
車を続けるという彼の
考えには実は理由がありました
それは彼の息子さん夫婦が経営しているお弁当の配達のお手伝いを彼はしてたんです
身体が不自由になっても何か瞳役に立ちたいそういう気持ちで一生懸命
配達の業務をこなされたと思います
ですから
最終的にはそういう彼の考えが家族の方も尊重して
だったら自動ブレーキとかついている新車を購入したらという条件で車の運転を有して
行ってもらったそうです
さらに安全性が高まるようにとワンペダルを一緒に取り付けることになりました
新車が納車される前に私はまずワンペダルに試乗していただきました
初めはエンジンをか月2ペダルの操作を確認しました
彼が問題なく操作できることを確認できたので車の往来の少ない
近所の蜜を今度は知ってもらいました
彼はエンジンをかけ
緊張な面持ちながらも笑顔を浮かべてゆっくりと車をスタートさせました
私はふと助手席に座ってたんですけども
ふと彼の横顔見たんです
その時彼の目からは涙が溢れていました
そのうち新車が納車されましてワンペダルを取り付けて今では少しずつ車の運転を再開
されています
彼にとって車の運転とは一概
そのものだったんですね
今こんな感じです
で私はよく免許の辺の
という問題を抱えている家族の方にあります
そして70代もしくは80歳80代の親御さんがよくおっしゃいます
あと3年乗るぜをか
しかし
家族からしてみればその3年間が非常に心配なのです
そして
被害者
2 jal も心配なんですけれども
加害者になるも強いんです
ですから私はそういうご家族の方が
ワンペダルを通じて
車のある日常
少しでも長く続いて
そして
うん
カーライフを終えられることを
願っております
ありがとうございました
[拍手]